[Music]
in the temple
at the heart of leicester's indian
community they pray
here the crisis that's unfolding
thousands of miles away feels
unbearably close to home
everyone is worried about someone for
syrendra who's a student here in
leicester
the fear is for his mum
he calls her twice a day anxious to
check
she doesn't have symptoms
since his dad died she's lived on her
own in a remote village where the virus
is spreading every morning and every
night i call her
he told me he hasn't been able to visit
her for over a year
and wishes he could be there now who can
look after her if if she got corona
who can take her to the hospital people
are scared now because there is no
oxygen the
hospital is full so all the people
are scared the community in leicester
have already
raised thousands of pounds to help
establish a field hospital
and send oxygen to areas most in need
this city has felt the terrible impact
of covid
a spike in cases here last year has left
many families grieving
so this is a family photo and this is my
father who passed away
last year sanjeev was also
seriously ill with the virus his
experience
makes him fearful for relatives in india
myself and my father ended up in
hospital in critical care
and unfortunately my father didn't make
it out
when i was ill the only treatment there
was that telomere on his oxygen
understanding that whatever other
facilities you've got if you haven't got
oxygen supplies
then your chances of survival are much
more slim
people here feel helpless as they wait
for news they can
only hope that better times are coming
becky johnson
sky news in leicester